I mean I've seen you met like Donald
Trump or something I saw him at the
fight last weekend Oh last weekend yeah
I saw him at the fights the other day
we'll fight with you yeah I met he was
at the UFC have you been to UFC
I ain't been over five you got to come
with me sometime man I'll be watching
them [__] them [__] is crazy as [__] bro
you would love it there bro hey last
week bro that was like two months ago
oh I saw him last week too who fought
last week
um this guy volkanovsky and another guy
yair Rodriguez where the the headliners
and uh
yeah but I met him two times
yeah do black people [__] with him more
it seems like it to me it seemed like
more black guys would mess with Trump
because he seems more
like connected to the culture a little
bit hey look I ain't gonna lie bro
the black community was not [__] with
Trump you know what I'm saying
but when that PPP [__] and all that [__]
came out
black people forgave them
because he helped out yeah
I'm speaking on the [__] in the
hood and [__] yeah I'm speaking on maybe
yeah
you hear me let them tell it even this
is what they say yeah
she
Biden ain't did nothing for us the [__]
Trump
was passing out money we [__] with Chuck
I'm like this are y'all back with Trump
just like that huh he was like [__]
like hell yeah they were passing out
money
I'm like dude that [__] crazy bruh
that's true though somebody showed up
with a couple of bucks man that'll
change the way you think about them yeah
yeah so yeah I thought it was
interesting I mean I didn't speak with
him too much but his son was there
I don't know I mean you know
I don't know how I mean I have different
I don't really trust a lot of these cats
you know I never really liked politics I
never trusted I never really trusted
politics man I never because we grew up
in like a poor area so if something was
happening in our area
nobody cared because we weren't paying
him taxes you know we didn't have a lot
of tax money so
they weren't really coming to help us
you know hey so would you tell them when
you met him
if he thought I could work in politics
one day
no he didn't but he's like yes you can
hear the best thing about Trump I will
say this right he's like you're doing
great you're fine you're good he goes
your parents are great I was like my dad
been there for 30 years
nobody goes but before that he was doing
good
bro I [__] laughs all the gang I
would have laughed too I would have
laughed bro I laughed so hard man
because he was right kind of he like
makes you feel you know he's just good
at shaking he just makes you feel
excited you know
um but he was real friendly he rolled in
with Mike Tyson man the first time that
I met him which was crazy and then uh
but yeah he seemed to be doing good
um who who did uh oh I did sit next to
his son one time because his son looks
kind of like a business guy you know I
mean you know I make the biggest [__]
Trump song ever
[__] Donald Trump that was your song no
way bro yeah bro you know that I didn't
even know that you think I was me and
lip [__] damn bro
congratulations so I wanted to like what
are you gonna like if I ever met a [__]
like what are you gonna say other than
me he probably like it's a good song
because it was a good song he would at
least give you that credit you know all
right all right you funny as hell he
would at least I think give you that
credit man but uh yeah I don't know
sometimes yeah it's interesting politics
is interesting because you start to see
like if certain communities are just
being used if certain communities are
just being uh taken advantage of you
know
um but
anyway man
uh
I'm trying to think of anything else we
want to talk about but I thought that he
was nice though he was nice yeah but
it's you know I don't know him I don't
know what he's like as a
business person and everything but he
seemed to just sit there and enjoy the
fights you know and grabbing business by
their [__] and [__] too right I mean
who a lot of people
who knows
uh dishwashing gloves that were just
like that bro
well yeah I do damn
you man he did yeah he was grabbing
people by the [__] man
but yeah and I guess some people don't
want they don't want that
they want you to just you know tap them
yeah and yeah he was doing it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one